shawn mendes is dropping new music and
his ex camila cabello is reacting on
tuesday the musician shared a snippet of
his new song on instagram
sean asks in the caption y'all dig this
and clearly for camila it's a yes she
jumped into the comments writing you're
crazy wildcat oh my god i mean i'm so
excited seems like there's no bad blood
with these exes they even still follow
each other on instagram it's incredible
the former flames broke up in november
after two years of dating the source
told et at the time that their split was
mutual explaining quote they realized
they are in totally different places in
their lives at this point and it was
time to end things they're both sad
about the split but doing their best to
take care of themselves stay busy and
surround themselves by loved ones
[Music]
seems music is playing a role in sean's
healing just last month the singer
released the breakup ballad it'll be
okay
[Music]
it'll be okay
of course music is something the singers
have bonded over for years they
collaborated on hits like senorita
[Music]
and 2015's i know what you did last
summer
back in december 2020 sean opened up to
et about writing songs with camila who
is more mushy when it comes to
songwriting i think we're both equally
very mushy and i think we're both
extremely mushy people we're both super
sensitive which it creates a lot of
sensitive sensitivity in our
relationship but we are songwriters so
we're constantly searching for the
sensitive topics in life there was also
talk of taking their relationship to the
next level is she your forever person
like do you talk about
an engagement one day do you talk about
it yeah
absolutely i think when you find your
person you feel and you know that you
found your person and when e.t spoke
with camilla during her cinderella press
tour she opened up about having sean's
support has it been fun to have sean
cheering you on as your real life prince
totally i mean he's uh you know he's the
best and i think we're really supportive
of each other and you know always want
to see each other like didn't he
surprise you for your birthday yeah he
did he surprised me about
the week of the ball and he saw me do
one of those themes yeah um he saw me do
the scene with the gong like where i
fall or whatever oh yeah um yeah and so
yeah he was he was he was there for the
whole beginning of it and uh was so
supportive and uh
yeah i'm lucky i have awesome people
[Music]
you